figlio di un verme si no che cazzo
sempre secondo moglie li mortacci di tua
sorella putrefatta eletti ragazzi o
cristo ma 9 partito già fermi aiuto come
si mette in palla volevo fare l'aie
vaffanc tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
movide sono vari j
ed oggi siamo tornati su slitte rio che
allora nell'ultimo episodio ho fatto i
culi ma poco i culi nel senso che gli ho
disegnati ho fatto dopo le chiappe sode
adesso per ripicca sono sicuro che sugo
per forza matteo modo ti fotto tutti i
punti frate tutti quanti grazie grazie
grazie grazie perfetto tech tutti quanti
è quanto era lungo sto tizio vediamo se
riusciamo a fare una partita recente
pure stavolta chemical l'altra volta mi
sono sorpreso di me stesso rega ma come
lo blocca vera mamma ciao e va bene si
sono uccisi petelin culo non ce la
faccio insomma troppo piccolo e va beh
sono stato scemo tra l'altro ragazzo ho
notato solo adesso che la classifica si
chiama top ten giro perché ovviamente
dei vermi grossi sono degli san gennaro
cosa chiede a san gennaro è cosa chiede
io dovevo chiamarmi sono giapponese rega
perché non l'ho fatto è come lo [ __ ]
e san gennaro vorresti potermi punti
adesso sono più grosso di thè san
gennaro mi dispiace io ce l'ho con te
san gennarello ucciderti san gennaro
perché sono giapponese ora perché sono
giapponese ti uccido san gennaro ma
quanti punti quanti punti vita ha
dimenticato un addio così significa che
è che scoraggi con l'altra è invece
significa pitt a quello di hunger games
pec e mi sa che scorre egidio mato mato
cosa sto facendo non l'ho fatto l'ho
fatto l'ho fatto l'ho fatto bene
la madre ga creazione che azione
ciao zio è ormai minchiate ho fatto
un'azione incredibile questo pensa di
potermi giri ma anziché mai studiato
almeno un po di fisica lo sai che non ci
arriveresti ma quanto sei scemo toni il
verme toni mi mancava il verme toni
perfetto sono settimo ragazzi sono
settimo ce la posso fare
come mi sono messo tutto storto non mi
ha ucciso quando sei scemo potete
uccidermi subito ero convinto di morire
ero convintissimo
bastava che non aveva bene cioè non sono
mi sto lamentando per carità di dio
agente che riesca inglobare forze no
perchè questo deve andare su che culo
partorito vi giuro modo che presa ma le
regate presa a testa di culo ormai
esultare prima di uccidere qualcuno però
adesso si trio adesso posso esultare due
volte direi ai ragazzi io vi dico
nell'ultima puntata sono arrivata a
33.000 ed ero ancora secondo quali basta
arrivare a 21 mila e sono già primo però
devo arrivarci prima che ci arrivi a
[ __ ] no sì no non lo posso andare però
perché mi inculano però mi sarebbe
piaciuto verme minuscolo mi stava
uccidendo vai vai
figlio di un verme porca vacca era
piccolissimo ma mi stava in cui la m ma
inglobato lui alla fine ma chiuso la
strada che nervi mica che odio che odio
profondo regala non ci posso credere ma
in groppa ora un nano è mai inglobato un
nano
c'è poi sono andato a sbattere su uno
più grosso ma amy ha inglobato la mente
un non ci posso credere perché questo
perché quelli grossi devono tartassare i
maroni ucciso ma vedi lo vedi quanto sei
scemo lo vedi perché eri grosso potevi
fare quello che volevo in de tuto
venirmi a rompere il bene allora non ti
lamentare se sei grosso gigantesco ma
lasciali stare quelli più piccoli ma
tanto che vuoi per due punti che sta
roba perché si chiamano poiché ci sono
un sacco di vermi minuscoli che si
chiamano così guarda cos'è ma non ho
capito è un computer
sì perché mi stanno sbattendo tutti
addosso perfetto grazie di punti gratis
cav h ma vado avanti sono nell'ammasso
meno amato 31 23
se mi ammazzano di questi mi metto a
ridere che non sono neanche giocatori
secondo me sono compiuto perché sono
tutti fermi ci vanno dritti si
schiantano come se non ci fosse un
domani ragazzi quando ne muore uno in
realtà poi è tutto un continuo morire di
gente quindi continuate ad hamas
cioè continuate a girare intorno alla
gente perché funziona tipo adesso
dovrebbe morire qualcun altro io se
fossi stato io sarebbe stata una roba
incredibile ok dai che fosse un globo no
che se n'è accorto arca [ __ ]
hai preso nel buchino e mi dispiace
frate hai lottato bene però lo ammetto
pronto sono diventato grosso
adesso faccio le cose grosse tipo
uccidere i vermi più grossi non che
questo qua è troppo grosso ragazzo
notavo sono entrati in classifica come
al solito vediamo di fare una cosa
decente stavolta magari arrivare primi
che dici gruppo tutti quanti mentre
cercano di prendere i punti vedo se
riesco ai ragazzi perfetto no sì che
culo che cool issimo ce l'ho fatta anche
in gruppo e questo vai vai perfetto no
perché mi chiami si stava salvando in
una maniera pazzesca era arrivato a
tanto così da salvarsi non ci posso
credere che culo o sono quarta quinto se
il cono ammazzare questo secondo me
arrivo quasi quasi primo sono un primo
direttamente non mi fate vedere va bene
ok perfetto anche lo si libera si libera
si libera si libera che culo
no non mi rubati punti e non mi ruba e
testa bene stronzo che culo secondo
quanto devo avere quanti punti per
arriva il primo che palle
vai vai vai vai vai sono a 17.000
madonna quanti punti sto facendo il
c8000 e 19.000 devo arrivare a 25 dai ce
la posso fare lega monica ciao monica le
mostro l'acqua tonica se non si fa
qualcosa non restare catania da morto
sono portos promo sono morto
sempre secondo moioli mortacci di tua
sorella putrefatta non c'è verso di
vivere mai o non c'è vera questo che
muore subito sono nato adesso sono
troppi coi non è morto anche per me in
teoria è però io sono più bello che
cappero vai vai è capito il casinò avevo
detto io quanto è va bene è morto quanto
stiamo lottando in un metro quadro di
vermi basta gente che muore continuo che
palle finché non sono io va bene però
mica che ansia c'è pazzesco non mai
vista una roba del genere perché su
tutti concentrati in un punto solo sono
un deficiente ora dove mi sono infilato
sono riuscito a fare retromarcia non so
come non so come va bene va bene va bene
fatemi tornare indietro che prima c'era
un sacco di gente che culo ok ok tac
morto niente ragazzi non c'è verso di bd
niente nella vita non c'è o che è morto
qua chloe è morta chloe ora quello
questo è scemo verme solitario è
grandissimo grazie per me solitario
senza di te lancia vari mai fatta su
carta perfetto e inizia a genocidio di
pa vj va depp averno mastra o cosa cazzo
sei iscritto league e nickname è quello
ma puoi trovarti un nickname che sia un
nick name normale per me solitario no è
in difficoltà ragazzi lo aiuto io parlo
da ta ta ta ta ta è morto è morto mi
prendo un po di tuoi punti così almeno
ci sarà un po di te in me ci sarà sempre
un po di te in merca [ __ ] quanti
punti quanta gente è morta qui facciamo
la gara se dobbiamo fare una gara
andiamo su motogp ragazzi di questo
tenta di inglobare qualcun altro ma lo
ingloba
[Musica]